britain's platinum jubilee honoring
queen elizabeth continues this morning
with a special church service in london
the royal family is all there including
prince harry and meghan markle this is
her first public appearance since a
couple gave up their royal duties the
queen however decided to stay at home
holly williams is outside st paul's
cathedral church in london holly we've
always heard that this is one of her
favorite events so what are you hearing
about her decision
good morning gail well the palace says
that the queen enjoyed the parade
yesterday but she spent a lot of time on
her feet and we know that she's been
experiencing mobility issues so it's
perhaps not surprising that she decided
to watch today's service of thanksgiving
on television at home in her castle
last night at windsor castle the queen
led a ceremony symbolizing unity
more than 3 000 beacons were lit around
the country and the commonwealth
as the uk celebrates her 70 years on the
throne
but the palace said the 96 year old
monarch experienced discomfort at
yesterday's military parade in her honor
and she reluctantly decided not to
attend today's service of thanksgiving
she will be disappointed not to be here
hugo vickers is a royal historian listen
at 96 years old we're so lucky still to
have her we saw her yesterday on the
balcony she looked amazing and
we mustn't ask too much of her
other members of the royal family were
cheered as they arrived this morning
charles and his wife camilla
william and kate
as well as harry and megan her first
official public appearance in the uk
since moving to the u.s two years ago
at yesterday's military parade only
so-called working members of the royal
family appeared on the balcony of
buckingham palace including
four-year-old prince louis who stole the
show
we caught just a glimpse of megan but
today a reminder of her undeniable star
quality if people behave well together
in public it makes it more difficult for
them to behave badly in private and you
know
so far the suspects have been very
discreet let's let's hope that continues
but it's the queen many came here to see
still wildly popular in her 10th decade
70 years reigning you know just really
pleased to be here experiencing this
event you know she did it i wanted to be
forever i want her to leave forever if
possible it's not possible i know that
but yeah
we all wish the queen well also notably
absent today is prince andrew his
reputation sullied by his association
with jeffrey epstein he's apparently
tested positive for covet
gail
thank you holly williams reporting from
london probably one of those rare times
when you might think okay if i'm going
to get covered now is the time you don't
have to have any explanation about why
you're not in yeah
the family finds that a little
convenient right
right but everybody looks so great
everybody looks great it's funny nate
and i were just talking because i said
wow look at that outfit i was talking
about kate's butter yellow and you were
talking about who i was talking about
the priests and the guys too they all
look so great everybody everybody's in
their finery with their medals lincoln
and everybody loves the queen i still
it's amazing they want her to live
forever forever at approval rating
through the roof yeah yeah the envy of
politicians everywhere yeah